I am gonna start with our first question
from zoom which is around journals so I
love this question around scientific
literature and open access advocate for
a decade or more so the question is do
you think open source journals should be
more accessible to the public why or why
not and so I think maybe there are two
certain questions here so this open
source stuff like bio archive med
archives and the og archive which is
like the math and physics open source
preprint server and then there's and
that's been around for a really long
time by the way
so math and physics people have had it
going on for way longer than biologists
so props to them but the peer-reviewed
stuff is really inaccessible so what I
would love to hear like everybody here
on our panel like where are you with
that do you think that this should be
open to the public
hmm so open to the public as in like
accessible to rapidly wild I guess yeah
I think that's the main thing that's
that's at least how I understood it and
I'm like Gina like geni a very big
advocate of open source and I have been
for a very long time but interested to
see what and Lindsay think okay for that
absolutely yes I want to clarify whether
it was like like accessible without a
paywall or accessible in a way that it's
written because I mean I think to like
to some degree that can also be made a
bit better
in terms of like the clarity with which
we write about our research but
definitely having the research at least
free like you know no price free
accessible to the public should
absolutely be the case in my opinion
yeah yeah I agree completely with
everything that I'm just said that's
great yeah I mean I think it makes
complete sense a lot of this research is
publicly funded so it makes complete
sense for the public to actually have
access to the results that you know
peer-reviewed results of this this
science so not just the archives but
actually you know open source
publications like you know plaus and
others would be
yeah there's a couple of journals like
Eli life yeah and I will say that all of
the kovat 19 stuff is open to everybody
on most journals I believe nature and
science for sure yeah great yeah okay
well oh sorry did you or maybe computer
you can take the next question okay cool
yeah that's what I was gonna - sorry I
think I got a little bit of audio
interference but yeah I think this is a
good question from Amanda and it goes
into the you know in fact if it
infectivity methodology that you were
talking about so what she wants to know
if these drugs were good on cells
already infected the drugs that did work
on cells that were already infected or
in cells before they were infected by
the virus
yeah so in this paper and in the figure
that I talked about they treated the
cells with the drug prior to infection
so kind of like prophylactically sort of
and so they also in this paper we didn't
talk about it they looked and they saw
that the drug was pretty good at
preventing infection for up if you gave
it up to four hours after you infected
the cells and so what that really means
in terms of in an organism like I really
don't know maybe someone else knows
better um but it's really hard to say
what four hours means in a cell in terms
of like the timeline and I think that's
a really important follow-up question
because obviously we need to find drugs
that can be used to treat patients who
already have Sarris Cody - and
prophylactic is great - but great so we
have this wonderful question from
facebook from Anissa and I you did not
talk about this explicit with me but if
you caught it in the methods like how do
they know if they prevent it or reduced
infections with these drugs in the cell
culture experiments
um so basically the way they did it was
I think this might have been part of the
idea behind designing it where they gave
the drug before the virus is they
basically like gave different cells like
+ - drug at the same quantity of virus
and saw like in theory like if the drug
does nothing you should see the same
degree of infection in both conditions
but if the drug is preventing infection
then you would see less infection in the
cells that receive the drug if that
answers the question but that was kind
of how they sought to measure that
difference in infectivity how do they
look at infectivity like how do they
measure if something is more infected or
less infected were you able to gather
that from the methods I believe it was
based off of just the amount of viral
proteins or the amount of viral RNA
within the cell um I believe that's what
they did
interesting cool thank you all right so
we've got another question here from
Joanne and they want to know what type
of cell lines were used for these
studies and I think you mentioned that
at some point if there were a long
cardiac or neural and they're referring
to specifically the amounts of the h2
receptor which we already know is
involved in the virus and the virus
entering the cells that exists in cells
from these different types of tissue and
they mentioned human cell lines I
remember you guys talked about monkey
cell lines at some point but I don't
know if you want to go into that more
detail
sure so for the original viral protein
human interaction experiments that we
saw at the very beginning those took
place in heck 293 T cell lines and those
are kind of like a workhorse online that
we use for a lot of like lives a lot of
stuff in cell biology even just kind of
like piloting and testing like certain
like gene editing experiments like a lot
of times we do them in two nine three
T's just because they're super easy to
work with so those are originally
derived from Cuban kidney cells or human
kidney I should say and then for the
later experiments the infectivity
experiments those were in I think there
were V row six good and those are monkey
kidney cell lines and we use those from
what I read particularly in
ecology because they're fairly easy to
infect and also like monitor infection
pretty easily so like they kind of
designed their cell lines based on sort
of like easily designing their
experiments and then getting very clean
results they can control for great and I
think this is a question that maybe I
could be the one to answer because it's
around how do students get involved in
biomedical research during this time and
as the director of Rafi tu who runs
biomedical research programs for
students I can tell you that I don't
know right now it's been a really tough
time for the research landscape I know a
lot of summer programs are being
cancelled I know for us our summer
science research program is going
virtual and so we are currently dreaming
up ways that we can provide research
experience to our students and beyond so
that they can go through the process of
science themselves and I just want to
point out that in terms of the process
of science what we really want to see
people doing is this like iterative
process you're gonna design something
you're probably gonna have some aspects
of it that fail you're gonna figure out
how that failed fix it up and then redo
it until you get an answer that feels
rigorous and can be replicated by
someone else in an independent setting
right and so that's the key to science
it really needs to be something that can
be replicated and stay tuned for our d4p
section we're hopefully going to have a
little bit more stuff coming soon in the
corner store science section that will
allow people to engage with the process
of science and and we're developing out
a couple of model systems that you could
do at home and so stay tuned for that
and hopefully we'll have a better answer
for you in the coming weeks for how to
get involved great ok then we'll move on
to the next question which is from
Samantha and Samantha wants to know how
long hope I think probably directed
actually at the two of you specifically
how long have you been following the
trials I'm guessing how long have you
been looking at clinical trials and
using all of the tools that you showed
us in the end that were super useful
um well not that long um so when I used
to look and when I used to work in
pharma I paid like a little bit more
attention to them and that's how I got
familiar with the process and generally
just from like kind of being in that
worlds and in that fields um but kind of
like I think is everyone you know has
with all the news that's going on and
like kind of the quick pace of like oh
like this drug seems to be working now
this drug seems to be working now we're
testing this drug like I've definitely
sort of tuned back into it again just to
try and keep tabs and everything that's
going on even still it's very hard I
loved your your sort of reminder at how
all the different phases where I thought
that was that was really really useful
Oh glad to hear it so I'm gonna ask a
question from Lauren and I love this
question so considering that the study
found that Tsarskoe b2 interacted with
332 proteins so just clarifying that
certain proteins within the Czar's Kobe
tube you know
proteome interacted with 332 human
proteins and so she has if a drug would
be needed to prevent all of these you
know do you have to make a drug to
prevent all of these protein protein
interactions or just a few yeah well so
I think I mean I think we would still
we'd still need to like figure that out
for sure but I doubt that that would be
the case if anything so well I guess an
example an example of this I guess I
would thought we could cite maybe like
tentatively from the study is that some
of the drugs that just targeted like one
or a few interactions did reduce viral
infectivity so it already suggests that
we don't need to go after all of these
these proteins which would be a doozy so
that's good to actually see some effects
and I think sort of what's maybe more
helpful or like could be more
informative to us to pay attention to
here is kind of like what particular
functions like we show us some those
interaction maps that show proteins that
are all involved in the same job like if
certain drugs that go after a certain
function are really effective at
preventing infectivity or reducing in
fact
then it might just be those functions
and then proteins involved in that
function that would be important for us
to target another caveat to this too is
as Lindsey mentioned the beginning the
way that they sort of did these
experiments is they expressed one viral
protein at a time and these human cell
lines and that's not how like a viral
replication actually happens because the
virus gets in it replicates its entire
self all at once so you'd have a lot of
viral proteins in a cell at a time so
it's possible that like in a condition
where you have this one viral protein
bumping around you might have
interactions happening there that you
wouldn't necessarily see as opposed to
normal infection where you have all the
viral proteins in the cell at once so
this is the kind of thing that would
have to be tested sort of empirically
but my guess would be probably not which
is good and I think it's worth adding
that most drugs that are small molecules
so most of you know like the stuff that
you sort of the pills that you take are
usually a small molecule and the small
molecule will typically only have a
single target right in just generally
speaking and so if they can disrupt one
of those targets they don't have to
disrupt everything else because that's
what we're just looking for so yeah I
think I think that's a really it's
really nice to think about in terms of
the science so cool okay so another
question from Magnolia now and she she
stresses it's a hypothetical question
but I still think it's it's a good
question and good to go into about the
FDA approval so she asks if an existing
drug was found to help treat kovat 19
and was FDA approved again so for that
purpose what effect could that have on
the people who already use that drug to
help treat other conditions is there a
way to produce medications on a larger
scale or are there restrictions huh yeah
that's great Lindsay do you want to take
this on I guess I'll start my real
answer is I don't know what kind of an
effect it would have I know and it's
been pretty like in addition to the news
talking a lot about how chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine maybe might treat
Kovan 19 there's also been a massive
shortage in those drugs for people
who actually need them to treat other
things like rheumatoid arthritis or
lupus and that's a really big problem so
I don't know the answer to how can we
mass if we find a drug that works how do
we mass produce it but I do think that's
a super important question to ask that
was my favorite niece Maggie so thank
you here's a question from Audrey I'm I
hope I'm pronouncing your name correctly
what evidence do they have to determine
it's a drug has effectively bound to
either that human protein or to the
viral protein to disrupt that protein
protein interaction hmm okay so for
human proteins generally like so the
sort of like the first way that people
will kind of validate drugs to see if
they bind is basically they'll look for
a drug that disrupts like if it's an
enzyme like a certain reaction the
enzyme participates in or like it'll
look for just like the separate proteins
that are both involved in the
interaction and see like if the drug is
there does this enzymatic reaction not
happen and now suggests the drug is like
preventing it from happening or these
two proteins that we can usually isolate
in a way that Lindsay describes while
they're stuck to each other are they no
longer stuck to each other when we give
the drug so there are sorts of like
that's kind of like the initial pass but
another way that people do is and
actually and this I'm not super familiar
with what I've just seen figures a bit
before we can do this technique called
x-ray crystallography that actually lets
us see like physically the protein and
the compound bound together and sort of
verify those chemical interactions where
the compound or the molecule I should
say is kind of like basically like
filling that binding pocket in the
protein like that actually lets us see
that it's truly happening but otherwise
it's more kind of like a functional sort
of like how does this protein babe like
do different things as you would expect
it to if the drug was binding to it
ok so I think this question goes back to
what we talked about a few minutes ago
actually about the giving the the drug
before after the cells were infected
with the virus but I'll still like let
you expand do you think that some of
these drugs at some point will be used
prophylactically for the general public
who is not yet infected to prevent
infection maybe I think that depends a
lot on like their other what are their
side effects they have so that's always
something that is kind of that's to keep
in mind with regards to kind of like
giving drugs for certain indications
there's always like a risk to benefit
ratio that you have to consider where
especially if it's a prophylactic if
that drug comes with some pretty harsh
side effects then you might want not
want to be taking it just on the off
chance that you might get an infection
but if you already have the infection
and it's really bad and there's nothing
else then you kind of are more willing
to kind of stomach the side effects if
it'll help you get better so I think
like that could come into play in terms
of those decisions but all of that stuff
has to be tested in trials so absolutely